[Music]
molotov off on catwalk so they can't
push out that angle but first still
above on the connector and they're both
gonna walk through first should peek out
at any moment
doesn't matter Zeke you can still get it
it's over just like that cloud nine get
obliterated against the Brazilians
kaboom I don't think anyone saw that
coming and cloud nine looks stunned they
look speechless and watch out world
Brazil's got a contender they look so so
so good as a team right man
honestly like to see that kind of team
play to see the execute to see this
individual skill that I'm super excited
tqk pushes towards passion for Stillwell
put the key like they had a great
showing this tournament and I think they
kind of proved everyone wrong that you
know nobody else other than American and
Europe can actually play well in these
events out of this position there's the
peak
they played different maps against
different teams had very very decent
result they just changed two players I
mean they should just look forward and
just try to focus on their weaknesses
but this is just something to build on
following trying to move close here
midair shopping Guardian he tries again
he still got a little help left jumps
around in a one-on-one and falling you
can tell he wants to carry his team back
here if we have to travel a lot if we
have to go to the moon back to be
champions we will men once luminosity
and eventually sk-gaming were on top of
the world with back-to-back major wins
and an era to call their own they had
turned Brazil into a counter-strike
powerhouse and every player on the team
was a person to be feared but those
players those results and that era have
all dwindled into mediocrity so what
happened to South America's greatest
talent
[Music]
by 2016 the all Brazilian luminosity
gaming lineup had transformed they've
gone from crowdfunding their way to a
tournament as kaboom gaming to becoming
the dark horse at the MLG Columbus major
fallen fur taco coldzera and FNX were
tactical aggressive and above all else
hungry to prove themselves
well that was a bit of a knock table
wasn't it [ __ ] to be going down FNX
trying to sneak in here and he drops the
Fryeburg and Frank mccolts here on taco
coming back into it is all now on forest
and frybread trans together I hear they
won't called Sarah fullen to end its
sixteen five in favor of luminosity
gaming and they are gonna move on in the
group they made quick work from the
group stage defeated in aggressive
virtus Pro in the quarterfinals and made
one of the most incredible comebacks in
counter-strike history against the
liquid in the semi
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's gonna hit the ground
there's cold
we do this corner safely velocity with
your way unthinkable seems there on the
P apartments they need a huge play but I
was something I'm never gonna see ever
again I have no words to describe oh my
holy okay Eco making its waves around
the smoke this family will spot Tucker
but that's in luminosity with a comeback
from 1510 an amazing play from coal with
the AWP all the way back into overtime
into a victory ten rounds in a row he
Kony's a big big play to save his team
in this round
and he's got a guy going towards
headshot his fur spray comes in the
flames are making it difficult but what
Kaneko do he's gone and phoenix jumping
through the smoke and addresses for
with an AWP and there it is cold is
going to take his head off and
luminosity will find themselves in the
grand finals against Navi it's like
accomplishing a dream for us he'll be
fighting so much in the last year's to
get here tomorrow we're playing I think
we're getting resilience I think this
thing's evolving is getting more
experienced and have to believe if every
time we change
we have excellent players and we can
manage to come back and I think this was
the greatest series I have ever won LG
were on the verge of making history with
only Navi left in their way ladies and
gentlemen here it comes Navi and
luminosity gaming in a best of three
grand finals for the MLG csgo major
championship now B they've been winning
every single one so far could they do it
a seventh time here C is gonna be
picking up and taken out fallen just
spraying with an m4 a1 and FNX in the
corner he's out in the open here he
still wins the fight goes to the peak he
knows that what's the age phrase and
there it is he gets the triple kill and
luminosity are in the grand finals
finally it's gonna be 6 1 : hiding
behind the boxes they need that second
round well see it's gonna reset them in
there
captain not the Brazilian TV picking up
a second kill for himself such a tough
rounds of windy and luminosity they're
trying to make it back in another two
kills and we'd be go to overtime sees he
has the bottle so he's gonna try and put
it out yes the sprayed down kills one
for with the reef right now all on
Edward piece out there the foam is
ticking away he gets the first killing
but it can't hit it the monitor I'm not
gonna save the round and we are going to
overtime and it would have to cut it
again it's our one B two they've got
almost no helping it definitely new this
looks for the shot he gets the one
killer
they don't even have a kid or any
pronates picked up right now Seuss just
too many bullets coming in his way
Edward gets the one kill he has to find
another one for the quad Tucker around
the corner Edward make it look the wrong
way he turns around for it please get it
do it for the double of Naveed they lose
the round luminosity 14 to 2 and now it
is a water to taco look at the see if he
can close it out here and win it for the
Brazilians it's gonna be a big
turnaround there hits that shot on soups
amounts of one-on-one Guardian versus
taco they may just be destined to be a
team winning their first major
championship fall and fulfilled a dream
a decade in the making and on top of
that
LG's wins solidified Brazil as a
terrifying presence in the world of
Counter Strike two months and two
victories later the boys from Brazil
found themselves embroiled in a contract
dispute that disqualified them from
competing a kneeling season why the same
roster emerged in time for ESL one
cologne under the sk-gaming banner ready
to dominate the cathedral of
counter-strike the current reigning
world champions the best team on planet
earth and in the grand final for a
second consecutive time they will walk
away from this with only one thing on
their mind a second consecutive title
Alicia
opens up on water called us here trying
to repeat the last round he's got the
first two he needs the third one as well
and he gets simple cold Sarah just a
walk of his team Paulin gonna be going
down but they will only get the
in one last attempt here if in explain
close to the trainees gonna help be held
up by fur and they're safer next finally
coming from with a spray and takes down
a filter now in the use the last man
left any drop they need to get cost this
shotgun taco mix of a kill he's still
alive I guess you have more cuts arrow
to close out the round and the harp it's
gonna be ten five favoring SK he's got
the pistol up there running him down and
just T were coming out right now that's
the third kill in the round my god
s cage go around away and now it's just
all in the details easy for SK to pick
it up here trying to walk through the
smoke but it's it's not gonna happen SK
gaming second major championship in a
row
we started with 16 teams we now crowd
the Brazilian side sk as the kings of
counter-strike the best counter-strike
team in the world the SK era is
officially there gentlemen
the Brazilians now dominate the
counter-strike sea Duncan I mean you
can't argue with back-to-back majors
barring a few stumbles best case spent
the rest of 2016 and the majority of
2017 winning IM sydney ECS season 3 and
while it wasn't a major that year they
won ESL one cologne two years in a row
so phelps could go he doesn't even need
to wait to go they walk into it it's
lined up that it's done and SK for the
home of the organisation we'll take a
second straight year cell one cologne
championship but despite winning EPL
season six and ending the year on top
change was coming
send them home the crowd is ready we are
at the flashpoint here at the Econo
serena Conine in a one versus four taco
can't do anything the mone safety
[Applause]
when you considered the kings of a
competitive scene there's no room to
breathe you're fighting off hungry
competition from all sides while just
trying to keep your own house in order
flashbang gonna go over the wall and now
that's gonna be probably confirmation
that they are coming 17 seconds a lot of
grenades in no one scene twist yet gonna
get the one killed jumping down picking
up a second a pea couple four twists and
that leaves fall alone he's gonna go
down and liquid do it knocking out
sk-gaming off the tournament and moving
right into the semi-finals
a massive upset a massive surprise for
everybody involved not least sk-gaming
I'm not sure they know what hit them on
that first half and once you begin to
slip there's not a lot of room to
course-correct
it's on firm all-on-four tournament on
his shoulders and skadoodle with the
office low taught in the last few rounds
has two kills Stewie on 100 HP still to
watch the palm and as he walks in it's a
crossfire sets - he's just getting into
position now and he'll spot him crossing
over cloud nine moves on and SK go home
so the team tried to change things up
they made changes to their roster they
changed sponsors entirely
give me another challenge for the face
in the MIB are guys that's of course the
Brazilians Plus Stewie
the former sk roster this double long
setup may have no effect that might be
are taking their time to commit they've
got plenty of it but it's not what so
many pressing positions got B wins his
fight but low on ammo or reloads the
unit he does have to crossfire from
tizian and the fire the kills are firing
int is Ian's done it it's just one man
left up with Coulter I can't find the
final kills it's big are going to the
playoffs and MIB are eliminated in group
stages they even brought in a sports
psychologist to help them with the
mental aspects of the game while
changing up their in-game strats the
absolute last time here for MIB arm
grenades gonna maybe do a little bit
tarik picking up one kill untwist I'm
not sure why he wanted to fight that
whatsoever but a lot more damage
actually coming in right now
oh and tarik finding another kill on
taco
on Turkey almost gets a transfer but not
quite 1610 in favor of Team Liquid as
they pick up the map win and
unfortunately for MIB our struggles
continue and my BR had tried in all
their results still sucks and the
problems were piling up
[Music]
that's surprise I mean Horner was doing
everything he could after MIB ours North
American experiment with Stewie 2k and
Tareq ended in early 2019 the squad
decided to get back to their roots I
might be are there legends of the game
they've been around forever they have
won a lot of tournaments and now they're
back to five of Brazilians to have this
family being in the team and I think
that's gonna take them like back to
where it belongs the effects are
rotating they've gotta stick together
this the best and there it is can you
believe it 16 two and favor of Mr BR
against the number one team in the world
what a convincing victory that is
astrology need to get a chance to get
going on this
finally some signs of life they're
former BR everyone's kind of took them
out of the running completely their
results speak to himself and rightly so
they welcome back taco and eventually
replace spelled with Lucas want who they
welcome from their old home of
luminosity game
the results didn't improve Terra's holds
the flight photos coming towards him
which is being done the time is ticking
if Santos picks this off it might just
be over falling on his own one before is
needed he's got the first the m4a4
there's up the ladder you point a finger
trying to cool employer into his
crosshair but it's not coming just yet
it's low it starts to dance it will be
it gold be takes away forward a
wonderful come back from big and they
will stay alive the new but familiar
Brazilian lineup suffered its biggest
setback when caldera an integral part of
Brazil's Championship winning family
announced that he was stepping down from
the roster go so coach baccarat compass
was deeply respected parque de Porres
kita memento is better this is indeed
Musashi Koganei honestly is gonna say
punch could revive it i mainly part 22
vinyl mi BR is still going and they're
using zeus their coach as a stand-in for
cold but his departure really feels like
the end of an era for brazilian
counter-strike we have to manage
expectations for the viewer ride and
normally for the miv our name we know
there's legends in that team they've won
majors you know no one's taking that
away from them just in their current
limbo period and state MIB are they are
the walking wounded right now this is
the perfect environment for anybody to
be picking up wins against them in the
world of counter-strike champions can
rise and fall in a matter of months at
the end of 2016 called zero was
considered one of the greatest players
in the world now he's looking for a new
home the whole Filipe rail is a
delicious and she's a human kobani his
father came to Faliszek ánotá cannot
reproduce a new chain kanka finished if
you change the funny anatomical is so
much work you say fatty marrow since
that's percent you see into ki Orakei
another measured the reality is that
even when that core roster was on top of
the world there were still problems
behind the scene both taco and coldzera
had thought about leaving multiple time
before they actually did this [ __ ]
achieve up it's unsightly chilling
thought of a semi-coma special somebody
dunno quest result yo killer site we can
speculate about infighting and broken
relationships and leadership issues
we can imagine all the scenarios that
would cause a championship team to fall
apart but in the end and if it really
matters what does matter is that a
handful of players who put South
American counter-strike on the map or a
shell of their former selves but they
don't have to be the members of that
team have shown us that they have what
it takes to be champions and they could
show us again after all they've been the
underdogs before I want this to to be
remembered as not only getting there
it's how we got there everyone said we
couldn't do it everyone said we didn't
have the talent and we did it way
different than everyone else in the
world thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages